y
día de diplomacia para intentar frenar
la crisis entre el kremlin y occidente
por el despliegue de tropas rusas en la
frontera con ucrania presidente francés
emmanuel más como se reunió con su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin en moscú
mientras alemania y eeuu muestran su
alianza con un encuentro en washington
se solucionó la crisis política en el
congreso de honduras los diputados
disidentes que habían elegido a otro
presidente de legislativo ahora
respaldaron la junta directiva de la
mandataria xiomara castró ex tendremos
los detalles desde tegucigalpa
y la sede del diario opositor venezolano
el nacional está en manos del líder
chavista diosdado cabello
la justicia embargó las instalaciones
tras una demanda por daño moral luego de
que el medio publicara un reportaje de
un diario español que vinculaba al
político con el narcotráfico
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda maría clara calle y es un
placer estar con ustedes comenzamos en
moscú desde allí el presidente francés
emmanuel majo afirmó que hubo puntos de
convergencia en la reunión de hoy con su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin en la que
discutieron la atención por el
despliegue de tropas rusas en la
frontera con ucrania mientras que el
líder del kremlin dijo que espera que la
situación se resuelva pacíficamente pero
advirtió que si la otan acepta a ucrania
como uno de sus miembros los países
europeos serán arrastrados a una guerra
con moscú nuestro corresponsable en
rusia xavier colás quien se encuentra en
ucrania para cubrir la crisis tiene más
información
pues la conclusión es que la diplomacia
aunque ha conseguido pocos frutos hasta
ahora va a seguir avanzando y de momento
va a seguir siendo la primera opción la
guerra en ucrania de momento no va a
empezar mañana vladimir putin aunque ha
mostrado pocos puntos de convergencia
con emanuel macrón sí que sí que ha
dicho que hay una base para seguir
trabajando sobre algunas de las
propuestas
esta noche el presidente francés también
putin ha hablado de las propuestas
norteamericanas y de la otan recordemos
que moscú había recibido ya esa oferta a
sus propuestas de seguridad y ha dicho
que va a contestar así que nos esperan
todavía unos cuantos días en los que los
políticos van a seguir dialogando lo que
queda por ver es lo que van a conseguir
vladimir putin también ha explicado hoy
cuáles son sus miedos sus preocupaciones
respecto a la entrada de ucrania en la
otan ha recordado que ucrania irá a
recuperar la península de crimea que
eeuu se se anexionó y esto según
vladímir putin podría conducir en un
futuro a que si ucrania forma parte de
la otan la otan se ve arrastrada a una
guerra con rusia el presidente macro les
ha mostrado a pesar de todo optimista ha
dicho que hay que seguir dialogando que
hay que crear una estructura
europea de seguridad para que esta
crisis tenga una salida pacífica
y mientras más y putin se reunían en
moscú el canciller alemán olaf scholz
viajó a washington para mostrar una
postura conjunta ante rusia el tema de
tensiones el gasoducto nor swing 22 que
duplicaría la cantidad de gas que moscú
le provee a alemania el presidente
estadounidense joe biden reiteró que si
hay un conflicto con moscú este proyecto
se tiene que acabar scholz no confirmó
la cancelación pero reiteró que su país
se une a las sanciones que eeuu ha
prometido contra rusia
así rusia invade eso significa que
tanques o tropas crucen la frontera de
ucrania
entonces no habrá north stream 2
[Música]
como ya dije que estamos actuando juntos
estamos absolutamente unidos y no
tomaremos pasos diferentes daremos los
mismos pasos y serán muy duros contra
rusia en honduras ya hay una única junta
directiva del congreso después de dos
semanas en las que los 17 diputados
disidentes no apoyaron al mandatario de
legislativo respaldó la presidenta
xiomara castró nuestra corresponsal en
tegucigalpa kenia torres tiene los
detalles la profunda crisis interna en
el congreso hondureño en el que dos
juntas directivas se disputaban el
control del mismo ha llegado este día a
su fin con la firma de un acuerdo
histórico entre el presidente del
partido libertad y refundación de la
mandataria ziomara castro y un grupo de
diputados disidentes del mismo partido
encabezados por jorge cálix quien este
día se ha comprometido a apoyar la
decisión de la mandataria y su junta
directiva propuesta encabezada por el
parlamentario luis redondo con esto se
pone fin a esta crisis que mantenía esos
sobran la gobernabilidad del país y que
impedían que castró llevara a cabo su
agenda legislativa encaminada a una
lucha frontal contra la corrupción y a
buscar soluciones a los profundos
problemas estructurales del país como la
pobreza la migración y los serios
problemas en materia educación y salud
aunque el acuerdo se llevó a cabo en
casa presidencial no estuvo la
mandataria ya que ella misma confirmó a
través de sus redes sociales que se
encuentra positiva por kobe de 19 estado
de salud es estable
el periódico venezolano el nacional está
en manos de diosdado cabello el número 2
del chavismo la justicia le entregó la
sede del medio luego de que a finales de
enero ordenara el embargo y es que el
nacional fue multado con 30 millones de
dólares por replicar una información que
decía que cabello era investigado en
eeuu por presuntos nexos con el
narcotráfico nuestra corresponsal en
caracas daniela zambrano nos explica
esta decisión fue calificada de ilegal y
además de irracional por parte del
presidente del diario el nacional miguel
henrique otero
recordemos que en 2015 el diario
nacional replicó una información del
diario abc de españa en el que se
informaba que diosdado cabello en ese
entonces presidente de la asamblea
nacional estaba siendo investigado por
eeuu por narcotráfico este género que
diosdado cabello impusieron una demanda
contra el diario talcual la patilla y el
nacional el juez decidió imponer una
multa al diario nacional que ascendió
los 30 millones de dólares embargar su
cd y ahora recientemente se conoce esta
nueva acción por parte de una jueza
hermana del actual contralor general de
venezuela elvis amoroso quien
antiguamente también era diputado del
partido socialista unido de venezuela en
el que prácticamente se remata este
inmueble y se le otorga a diosdado
cabello el presidente editor del diario
nacional aseguró que fueron los últimos
en enterarse de esta supuesta subasta
pública a la que cualquier persona podía
acudir para participar y que sólo habría
asistido el abogado y has dado a quien
se le entregó el inmueble esto ha sido
calificado por organizaciones defensoras
de la libertad de expresión y también
por parte dirigentes políticos por como
una acción más de la administración de
nicolás maduró en contra de la prensa
libre
hablemos ahora de las noticias del coi
19 porque chile comenzó a vacunar con la
cuarta dosis a las personas mayores de
55 años el 10 de enero el país ya había
empezado el refuerzo con las personas
inmunosuprimidas y ahora amplía el
programa de vacunación para gran parte
de los adultos todo esto en medio del
avance de la variante omicron que tiene
los contagios disparados en la nación
austral
y un minuto de silencio hubo en el
capitolio de eeuu por los más de 900 mil
muertos que ha dejado el cob y 19 en ese
país la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi el líder de
la mayoría del senado jack summer y los
miembros de la cámara y del senado
hicieron el homenaje en los escalones
del congreso mientras que las campanas
repicaban atrás de ellos eeuu es el país
del mundo donde la pandemia ha dejado
más fallecidos
y un adiós a ryan of ram en marruecos se
realizó el funeral del niño de 5 años
que la semana pasada cayó a un pozo y
permaneció cinco días atrapado hasta que
las autoridades rescataron su cuerpo el
sábado cientos de dolientes se reunieron
para presentar sus respetos finales aquí
les contamos la historia
afligidos presentan sus respetos en el
pueblo de grano ryan de 5 años fue
enterrado el lunes después de las
oraciones del mediodía su muerte ha
conmocionado a marruecos estuvo atrapado
en un puesto durante días mientras los
socorristas luchaban por salvarlo a ryan
fue rescatado el sábado y trasladado en
una ambulancia pero no sobrevivió para
afinar a estar estamos muy tristes por
ryan hemos pasado un día muy difícil
pudimos respirar cuando sacaron el
cuerpo de rayán youtube todo el mundo
hizo lo que pudo las autoridades la
protección civil no tengo nada más que
decir damos gracias a dios por todo
el niño fue sepultado junto a otros
miembros de su familia
marroquíes de a lo largo y ancho del
país acudieron al pueblo para rendirle
homenaje
muchos se enviaron sus condolencias a
los padres de ryan
y todos los marroquíes han hecho grandes
esfuerzos para nosotros ahora estamos
bien y no necesitamos nada
las circunstancias exactas de cómo cayó
al pozo aún no están claras
la mayoría de los pozos de la región
montañosa del rif del país norafricano
tienen tapas protectoras
llegamos al final de las noticias
gracias por elegirnos
[Música]